now it's time to hear the nominees for
2019 we begin with the best performance
for a leading actor in a play BB start
us off please
Paddy Considine the ferryman Bryan
Cranston Network Jeff Daniels To Kill a
Mockingbird Adam driver burn this
Jeremy Pope choirboy and the nominees
for Best Performance by an actress in a
leading role in a play our BB again
Annette Bening Arthur Miller's All My
Sons Laura Donnelly the ferryman Elaine
May the Waverly Gallery
Janet McTeer Bernhardt Hamlet Laurie
Metcalf hillary and clinton heidi shrek
what the Constitution means to me and
the nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a leading role in a musical are
mr. Dixon if you please
Brooks ash Mantzoukas the prom Derrick
Baskin ain't too proud the life and
times of the temptations Alex Brightman
Betelgeuse diamond ah no Rodgers and
Hammerstein's Oklahoma Santino Fontana
Tootsie that's interesting to see just
opened April 23rd go Scott Sanders for
that the nominees for Best Performance
by an actress in a leading role in a
musical are Brandon Stephanie
[Applause]
kaitlin cunanan the prom best level the
prom even the bazzara hades town Kelly
O'Hara Kiss Me Kate veteran and the
nominees for Best revival of a play are
Arthur Miller's All My Sons the boys in
the band written by Mark Crowley burn
this torch song written by Harvey
Fierstein the Waverly gallery written by
Kenneth Lonergan the nominees for Best
revival of a musical are Kiss Me Kate
[Applause]
Rodgers and Hammerstein's Oklahoma and
this is a really big category the
nominees for Best Play are Brandon
Victor Dixon who is it choirboy written
by Tarell Alvin McCraney the ferryman
written by J's Butterworth Gary a sequel
to Titus Andronicus written by Taylor
Mac Inc written by James Graham what the
Constitution means to me written by
Heidi Shrek
the nominees for Best Musical
Brandon ain't too proud the life and
times of the temptations Beetlejuice
Hades town the prom and Tutsi there are
definitely some favorites there but I
have to ask you are you surprised that
neither Network or to kill a mockingbird
were nominated for Best Play the actors
were nominated Jeff Daniels was
nominated and Bryan Cranston but did it
surprise you we all wish that be but
that's not the question alright Brandon
and BB we thank you guys thank you for
joining us so there you have it Noren
john the top eight categories for the
2019 Tony Awards the the nominations
will continue here but we're going to go
back to you in the studio what do you
guys think of the list well they were
applauding their answers in advance I
was surprised that the network and also
to kill a mockingbird were not nominated
for for Best Play yeah and some actors
and actresses I thought might be on the
list as well but it also just gave me a
list of things I'm now I know so that's
great - all right thanks Gail and the
two of you one more word Gail from you
no I was just gonna agree with you John
I now want to see the prom I now want to
see Hades town I now want to see the
ferryman and I've seen a lot of things
but this just reminded me how many more
things I need to go see so I'm with you
you know beyond that and what we've
heard in the interviews leading up to
this and in those Broadway lovers that
you talk to is the energy that exists
when an actor is on stage and an
audience is in conversation with them
even when they're sitting quietly is
like nothing you've ever experienced
before for anybody who's not been to see
a play or musicals so go tickets well
said and when will the 2019 Tony Awards
be well nor the 2019 Tony Awards will be
hosted by the Late Late shows host James
Corden
nelle air Sunday June 9th